字幕: Masako Suzuki
校正: Hiroko Kawano
こんにちは
皆さんはアウトドア お好きですか？
もうばれちゃっているかも知れないですけど
僕 大好きなんですよ
（笑）
僕にとって
この「長野県」「アウトドア」
っていう２つのキーワード
ちょっと置きますね すみません
たった２つのキーワードですけど
僕 頭の中にはすごいいろんなシーンが
思い浮かんでます
なぜかというと僕は 長野県でアウトドアに
特化したカメラマンなんですよ
で すごいシーンが思い浮かんで
いるのと同時にですね
すごい可能性も感じています
で その可能性を紹介したいんですけども
僕の目線から 長野県を改めて
ご紹介したいと思います
宇宙から いってみましょう
（笑）
はい
地球の中では …
はい 地球上の中でも
最も水が豊かなエリアですね
で 小さな島国です 日本は
[小さな島国　JAPAN]
で その中でも本当に
中心にあるのが長野県です
で 山岳としては すごく
良いフィールドになっています
その山岳フィールドの中に
僕にはどう見えているかというのを
写真で30秒間で動画を
作りましたのでまずはご覧ください
（音楽開始）
夏から冬まで すごい良い景色があって
アウトドア・アクティビティ－にも
すごい数があるんですよ
皆んな いろんな遊び方をしていて
皆んな 楽しそうなんですよね
普通は山岳っていう風に見たときに
山って思うと思うんですよ
けど
僕に見えているのは こうなんですよ
（音楽終了）
はい これが僕に見えている長野県です
これ全部僕が撮った写真なんですけど
ちょっと疑ってませんか？
（笑）
大丈夫ですか？
そんなことを よく聞かれるので
今日は僕が撮っている裏側をご紹介します
こんな感じです
はい こんな感じ
これはですね 「シット・オン・カヤック」
っていう普通は座るボートなんですよね
けど どうしても撮りたい目線があって
ちょっと立ち上がって
もうこんなんですよ こんな
僕が持っているカメラって
3～40万円ぐらいするんですよ
だからこれ 相当なチャレンジの撮影です
で さらに
これです
どうしてもクライマーをかっこよく撮りたくて
ちょっと僕をロープで釣ってくれって言って
お願いして こんな感じの撮影をしたりとか
あとは
冬山に泊まって 星を撮ろうということで
マイナス20度とか最高いっちゃうんですけど
そういうとこに泊まって
星を撮ったりしています
これもチャレンジ撮影です
撮影もそうなんですけど
僕 体験もしてまして プレーヤーとして
ウェイクボードをやってみたりとか
あとアイスクライミングといって
氷の壁を登るやつですね
あとは乗馬
スノートレッキングみたいなことを
いろいろやっています
僕 こんなことをしているので
あだ名がついちゃって
それがですね 「チャレンジ君」
（笑）
こうついちゃって
名刺まで作っちゃったんですよ
調子に乗って
でさらに調子に乗って
「どんなところでもいつでも行きます」
っていう風に名刺に書いてしまったら
とんでもない取材が
きてしまうようになったんです
例えば「４日間寝ないで
アドベンチャーレースを追ってくれ」とか
レースですね 自然の中で
「マウンテンバイクを担いで —
こんな感じで —
3000メートルの山を縦走しよう」とか
そんなのが入ってきちゃって
でも僕は チャレンジ君は断れない
ということで行きました
で 僕が何をやっているかというと
ナガノアウトドアレジャーガイド「goat」
っていうウェブサイトをやっています
ここで「チャレンジ君冒険記」
っていう体験記を書いていたりとか
あと長野県のアウトドアレジャー
を紹介しています
写真 動画 ブログ記事ですね
これで 多いのは
写真100枚使ったりとかして
徹底的に紹介しています
そんな僕が思ったこと
長野県って世界に誇れるんじゃないか
と思いまして
なんでかというと 僕は
写真投稿のSNSのインスタグラム
というのをやっているんですけど
外人さんからの反応が異常に良くて
「awesome」とか 「beautiful 」とか
「hell yeah!」って —
「鬼ヤバイ」っていう —
そういう言葉が入ってきて
これはすごいなと
「世界に通用するんじゃないか
長野県のアウトドア」って思ったんですよ
で ビジュアルだけじゃなくて
数字も調べてみました
こちらです
皆さん この３って分かりますか？
僕ちょっと贔屓目に長野県を見ていますけど
３はこれです
３大都市圏から車で３時間
車で１時間のドライブって
結構近いと思うんですよ
３時間ぐらい行ってもらえれば
ああ遠くに来たなと
非日常だなと思ってもらえる
ちょっと贔屓目線です
50っていうのは
日本百名山のうち約50山が
長野県からアクセスできます
これもすごい山岳フィールドですね
で こちら はい
スキー場の数 これは86ありまして
日本国内の25％が
長野県に集中しているんですよ
もう選びたい放題
キャンプ場の数119
これも日本第２位です
3000メートル級の山が16山あって
これも国内最多ですね
数字でこんな風に表せられるんですけども
表せられないものがあるんです
もう未知数 — これは
良い意味で未知数なんですけど
僕はフェイスブックもやってるんですけども
皆んな 日々投稿をあげてくる中に
「こんなとこ行って
こんな遊び方しましたよ」とか
「こんな道具開発しましたよ」とか
もう きりないな と
遊びを取材しても取材しても 全然足りない
しかも「これは長野県だけで一生かかっても
遊べないんじゃないか」と
ちょっと思いました
さらに無限で —
これは僕自身の目線ですけども —
雪質なんですよ
こんな感じです 長野県
これはですね 世界からも
実は「ジャパンパウダー」で
「ジャパウ」っていう愛称で呼ばれているほど
有名なんですよ 日本のパウダースノーって
世界有数のスノーリゾート
アメリカ、カナダ、スイス、スウェーデン
そこからトッププレーヤーが
来てるんです 長野県に
僕も雪山に登ってるんですけど
よく外人に会った時に言われるのが
「まあお前ら良いとこ住んでんな」と
そういう風に言われて
そこでも「長野県もイケるな」と思いました
こういう風にいろんなものを確信して
僕が「長野県ってこういう風に
したらいいのに」って思ったものを
ちょっと作ってみちゃいました
これです
アウトドア県長野
これ ロゴも作っちゃいました
（笑）
これ 結構 かっこよくないですか？
「いや もうある」
みたいな感じではないですか？
（笑）
こんなイメージで長野県をPRしていったら
とにかく「楽しいな」と
「行きたいな」って
思ってもらえるんじゃないかな
って思ったんですよ
で またちょっと調子に乗って
さらに作っちゃいました
ポスター はい
（笑）
これも結構クオリティ高くないですか？
僕 良いと思うんですよね
これが東京の駅の構内とかにあったら
結構インパクトあるし
東京で仕事に行くお父さんたちが見て
「いいなあ」と言いながら 出勤していく
こんな感じになるんじゃないかな
と思ったんですよ
で 僕がここまで長野県の魅力に
前のめりになる理由がですね
ある取材があったんです
僕はこの活動を２年間やっているんですけど
その最初の方に 感動したツアーがありました
これ
これは体験ツア－なんですけど
何も使わないし 何も乗らないんですよ
なのにお客さんが大感動をして帰って行く
何をするかというと
まず白馬なんですよ
真っ暗な林道を30分間だけ歩くだけです
で 参加者は都会の家族
で スタートするんですね 真っ暗な林道を
最初は子供たちが「怖い 暗い」って言って
親にこう しがみついているんですよね
で ずっと歩いていく
まずガイドさんがピタッと止まって
「皆さん 今 気付きましたか？
今 足元が砂利からウッドチップに
変わったんですよ」
皆んな 「おお」とか「柔らかい」みたいな
さらにまた歩いていきます
そうすると またピタッと
ガイドさんが止まって
「じゃあ皆さんここで１分間
目をつぶりましょう」
で「耳を澄ましてみましょう」
って言って 目をつぶる
そうすると 虫の声がきれいに聞こえてくる
あと「ガサガサ」ってどこか遠くに聞こえる
「フ－フー」ってなんだか
分からないけど動物の声がする
で「目を開けましょう」って開けるんですよ
「皆さん 聞こえましたよね？
実は動物たちも こういう風に
僕らを察知してくれています」と
「なので彼らも無駄な争いはしたくない
なので避けてくれてるんですよ
そういうのが森の世界なんですよ 」
という風に教えてくれるんですよ
で ガイドさんが
「上を見ましょう」って言ったら
子供たちが「わあ明るい 星きれい」
って言うんですよね
目を１分間つぶっていたので
目が慣れているんですよ
で 親にしがみついていた子供たちが
急に自分で歩き出す
自分でどんどん進んでいく
あ これは「自然ってすごいな」と
「ありのままで もう都会の
家族にとっては感動なんだな」と思って
さらに「遊ばせ方うまいな」
とも思ったんですね
このガイドさんたち ツアーの人たち
で 実際こんな感じなんです
本当に イメージは
昼間 僕行ったんですよ
「本当にどんな場所なんだろうな」と
「これかよ」っていうぐらいの普通の林道で
（笑）
もうがっかりしちゃうぐらい
「これは見せない方が良い」
と思ったんですよね 家族には
それぐらい「遊ばせ方がうまいな」
と思ったんですよ
であともう１つ「遊ばせ方がうまいな」
っていうレッスンプログラムがありまして
「パンダルマン・キッズスクール」っていう
軽井沢でやっているものですけども
これがですね
「スキーを履いて滑ろう」というのではなくて
「スキーを履いて遊ぼう」なんですよ
写真みたいに「ボールをパンチしよう」とか
「スキーを履いてベルを鳴らしに行こう」とか
っていう風に遊んでいるうちに
スキーの感覚に慣れて
こういう風に滑れちゃうんですよ
これもまた「遊ばせ方がうまいな」と
子供たちにとって すごい大事なのって
楽しい失敗じゃないかなと思っているんです
で できなかったことを楽しく
できるようにしていくという中には
自分に自信が持てるんですよ
「自分はできる」—
そういうことを遊びの中から
子供たちが頭の中にインプットしていく —
そういうことができるので
「これは遊ばせ方がうまいし
すごい意味があるレッスンだな」と
思ったんですよね
「遊ばせ方がうまい人たち」
っていうのはもちろんいる
で 「遊び方がうまい人たち」
もいるんですよ 長野県には
その共通点を３つ 僕は見つけまして
ちょっと独自ですけども
お伝えしたいと思います
まず１つ目「山にはまず登らない」
これは僕もそうです
こんな感じで スキー・スノーボードを
最初にやっていて
山って楽しいなっていう風な
入口から入っているんですよ
そうすると もっと上から登ろうとか
で どっかで「ピークに行きたいな」
っていう風にて思うんですよね
皆んな 共通点としては
「山が楽しい」という風に入っています
で ２つ目
[楽しむ秘訣②「ご褒美を持っていく」]
アウトドアを楽しんでいる人ほど
すごくしっかりしたご褒美を
キャンプとか山に持って来るんですよ
例えば こんな感じでコーヒーですね
山の中 電気すらないのに
挽きたてのコーヒーを飲むとか
好きなお菓子を持っていくとか
それによって 楽しみができるんですよね
で 友達も誘いたくなるって
いうようなことがあります
皆んな 絶対しっかりしたご褒美を持っていく
で あとは「不自由な場所を楽しむ
という目線を持つ 」
これがすごく大事で
さっきも[言ったように]電気や
水道のない中で過ごした時間
対 街の中っていうのは
すっごく快適ですよね
幸せなんです それだけで
だから それを体験することによって
普段が幸せに感じられる
これがまた楽しい１つなんですよ
ずっといるわけには
やっぱりいかないと思うんで
今 アウトドアグッズ好き
っているじゃないですか
僕も大好きなんですけど
あと『GO OUT』っていう
雑誌もあるじゃないですか？
それで特化した専門誌が出るぐらい
アウトドアグッズ好きな人は使いたいんですよ
「使うには どこに行ったらいいの？」
っていったら
この不自由な場所に行くしかないですよ
しかも それを使うのは楽しいし
防災にも役立つっていう目線なんですよね
だから一石二鳥なんですよ
皆んな 楽しんでいる中で
日々の生活の中にも役立てていい
そういう遊び方を 皆んなしています
僕もそのプレーヤーの１人です
なので この冬行ってきた
体験ツアーをご紹介します
「不自由な場所に行く」というテーマです
はい 雪山を登ります 結構深いです
ここに泊まります
これは不自由ですよ
かまくらを作って この中に泊まるんですよ
この中に泊まっています
この中で何をしているかというと
大宴会
（笑）
大宴会 いっぱい持って行って
また グッズとかもないと
こうやって楽しめないんですけど
バーナーで火で 沸かしたりして
お酒を持って行って
ここで宴会をするんですよ
この特別感がすごく楽しくて
ここで食べたカップラーメンの味
まあ おいしかったですよ
外に出るとこんな景色です
街の灯り
星空
僕らにとってはこれもご褒美です
「これを見に行こう」って
いうので十分成り立つ
朝
雲海がピタッと止まって
もう絶景すぎる
で 朝食会場 ここです
これが朝ごはんです
これは美味しかったですよ
で 僕 こうやって楽しんでいるのも
もちろんなんですけど
「アウトドアの中にはすごい大事なことが
いっぱいあるな」と思っていて
チームで連帯行動をして
山の中に遊びに行くっていう中には
楽しくしたいっていうモチベーションで
それぞれが何か役割を果たそうとするんですよ
それでリーダーになる人がいれば
ムードメーカーになるような人がいたりとか
それぞれが役目を果たして
すごいツアーというか体験ができるんですよね
「それって実社会でも応用できるな」
と思っていて
ある会社のプロジェクトをやっている時には
じゃあ 自分はどの役割を果たしたらいいか
っていうことを真剣に考えて
すごい仕事をする
こういう頭の中の仕組みを
遊びながらやるからこそ
滅茶苦茶本気になるんですよ
で そこで成功体験をする
アウトドアの中には厳しい反面
すごく大きな価値があるんじゃないかな
と僕は思っています
大事なことっていうのは
「遊ぼうとするからこその学び」
ここから僕も多くのことを学んでいまして
僕はただ こう写真を撮ったり
しているだけではなくて
皆んなの行動を
カメラマンなんで 見るんですよ
そうすると「今あの人はすごい成長した」とか
いろいろ見えてくるんですよ
っていうのが「長野県」だと僕は思っていて
長野県はもちろん四季があって
すごく綺麗な景色がもちろんあります
さっき言ったように
「遊ばせ方がうまい人」がいる
「遊び方がうまい人」もいる
レジャーも滅茶苦茶いっぱいある
そういう長野県は「アウトドアの聖地」
じゃないかなと僕は思うんですよ
ちょっと今ロゴが小さいですね
（笑）
ちょっと弱気に...
弱気じゃないです
これはもう言い切りたいです
僕が言いたいのは いろいろ言いましたが
シンプルです １つ
長野県で
家族と
仲間と
とにかく一緒に遊びましょう
きっと 皆さん それぞれに対して
プラスなことがあるはずです
ありがとうございました
（拍手）